[Music]
so
remember back when you were underage and
you were like let's say 15 to 17 high
school age
do you remember ever being attracted to
an older woman oh all the time that's
all i was attracted to
like a real one like that was within
your circle or like you talking about
like beyond the threshold of like age
appropriate like they're 23. yeah yeah
like you were the young dude that you're
underage and you were like i was trying
to get molested by those hot girls
oh like hot teachers like that sure hot
teachers of course you had a hot teacher
substitutes
like attractive teachers she wasn't like
smoking hot but i was like oh man
if she wanted me detention every day i'd
be down you're also not seeing your
teacher's true potential that's true i i
had one hot as [ __ ] teacher bruh that i
was just like what was he like bro he
was really nice had
soft hands
i did have one hot teacher though that
she was a baddie yeah yeah
now i remember i still remember because
i was 18 like in the beginning of my
senior year i didn't finish school but
like in the beginning of it i turned 18
and she had uh
i don't want to like say her name say
her name no but
we were in class once and i had started
already getting tattoos right so i had a
bunch of tattoos already and um i was
sitting in the back and she was sitting
back there and she was really cool and
she was like oh you you got tattoos
already and so i started showing her
like my arms and like i had my feet done
i had my side done already and she's
like i was like you have any tattoos
she's like yeah but they're in places i
can't show you and smiles i was like let
me just see real quick whoa
that's what you said yeah
oh [ __ ] was this in college
high school in high school senior year
and um i swear to god when i said let me
see it real quick she was like
and i was immediately hard as [ __ ] i was
like god damn bro i see videos like this
bruh she was yeah did she show you nah
she didn't show me but what a prude and
she's patty
we have each other on facebook every
once in a while look she's still back
does she end up showing you where it was
no no what if it's like a hardcore
butterfly on her [ __ ] [ __ ] like
thighs and [ __ ] but there were stories
on her [ __ ]
that's the body part there were probably
just like makeups but there was like
stories that she had done stuff for like
a playboy like pictures and stuff and it
was like brought up and like i guess
like two years before we even came to
that school like made her cry she like
walked out so like why
i don't know but she was hot as [ __ ]
when somebody made her cry because like
these rumors started coming out that she
was a playboy model remember that
counselor at kepler yeah i know she
misses matsuo or something like that
matsuo she was pretty hot she was pretty
bad i remember she would wear these
slacks all the time and it would like
hug her ass
is it hot
we need to go to your office and talk to
get into trouble
is it
is it
matsuo
i don't know [ __ ] her last name actually
changed three times because i think she
kept getting married she kept getting
married
dude hell yeah it was like it was like
miss lay at one point miss matsuo at one
point it would change like every other
year
because she's so hot you know i remember
halloween too that teacher she dressed
up in this like little like cowgirl suit
you're both going wow oh my god for real
you think about staying in class all day
teachers that do that you think they
know what they're doing of course oh
yeah of course with the [ __ ] like
adolescent children young adolescents
that are like going through puberty yeah
that you have to understand and in my
head i was like i'm [ __ ] 18. we can
do this i don't give a [ __ ] like we're
not gonna get in trouble so sure oh my
gosh nothing oh yeah that's right you
are like already a major dude i never
had any really like hot teachers man
either teacher i had was mr davis and he
was seven eight years old he's a guy and
he his dr he was a physics teacher and
he would write like word problems and
his favorite thing would be like his
dream car he would always say it
was a green miata and he would put that
in all of his like physics is that why
it became your dream no that's why he
had a meal that's why he wear green
right now yeah yeah cases are i'm gonna
show you how to frame
no that's not her enough oh
that's [ __ ] mature from [ __ ] mark
kevin
that's not here pull up the picture of
your teacher dog
yeah pull up that other team she looked
like she was hot enough to be like on
the cover of import tuner yeah dang
kelly who but she's wearing like
business clothes every day business
clothes
i know lucy little lucy lou and we're
like all the guys are like ryan did you
have any
that's her
song hi lady
lady
miss song hi lee
no i didn't have any of that growing up
i think uh in seventh-day adventist
school it's a little hard to come by
yeah there's no teachers not really i
mean now i think there might be because
there's just like younger staff yeah but
in the schools that i grew up in they
were like people that have been teaching
since like the 60s yeah
so they were probably hot back then
yeah before prohibition
i was so afraid of like authority
figures at that age too i just wouldn't
look people in the eye i'd be like
i was like nervous all the time they did
not make it submissive
i was probably naturally very submissive
oh you know what you know what our
school
do you remember that uh
that black teacher i forgot her name but
then she taught keyboards i i
forgot a computer teacher right yeah i
think so so
she did yeah she got kicked out i didn't
know that but what i do know that is my
friend so you know she lived next to the
school her house was right there
so um
and then i think she had kids she's
really young right
no she was she she wasn't young but
anyways um
we're saying this because we went to the
same junior high or or high school she
was a junior high teacher one of my
friends
um so it also was a private school
christian school so the teachers had a
closer relationship with the students
and then so they would go over to her
house to play or whatever and then um
something happened where it was like oh
can i get this thing and she goes yeah
sure it's in my room just go ahead it's
in the drawer go up in this and then so
he looked in and he found a dildo oh
not of god but then he told us is it
cross-shaped though
oh yeah so so so he was like he was just
like yeah uh that he told us this whole
dildo story and back then i was just
mind blown that someone that is a
teacher of god would have a sex toy and
especially because in my head i thought
older women were just like not sexual oh
yeah yeah i just thought they didn't we
believed all the stigmas wait she kept
it in her [ __ ] in her school office
and he said he was like shocked you guys
ever seen but then he like obviously
closed it and he's like oh i can't find
it
you ever seen that vine remember when
vine was a huge thing and there's that
old lady my old grandma she's like
sitting on a bed you know what i'm
talking about and she starts singing
that one song i live with the monster
that's under my and then she pulls out
the biggest dildo
this is your mom for a teacher that's
banging dude dude her let me see it's
doesn't even matter dude i'd be [ __ ]
doing poetry in her class
writing love letters she's hot
i'll be failing all my classes on
purpose yeah show that but just take a
word for it yeah we don't want to dox
nobody hair dachshund yeah that's real
and she looked young too yeah this well
that was that was two months ago that
picture you're friends with her on
facebook yeah two months ago
damn then what year was it that you like
had her in school uh 2012. oh wow she
looked like she was 19. wait so what's
the point of asking us about that that's
just the point we have oh i thought you
were going to tell us some news about
like no this is not an article this is
just this is awesome
i wanted to know if you guys ever had
those situations where you were the
underage one
trying to go after the overage one this
is well i mean i've said before like i
always try to put myself in situations
yeah how would you do that get like
um taken advantage of
because like seriously like you're jail
beating yourself it was jailbaiting
myself putting yourself out there i had
this
heightened sense of confidence where i
thought like if i just had really good
like flirting game right like i could
get girls like older than me
and i've achieved it one time when i was
19 i got 23 year old but that's still
like not that different that's a big
deal high school or it started in like
junior high because i always thought
girls older than me were like they look
better
um they're more developed they're more
cooler whatever they could go out
so then like i'm like i don't [ __ ]
date girls my age like i want [ __ ]
high school girls obviously they just
thought it was cute that like i'm like
trying my best to [ __ ] flirt with
them and [ __ ] and then they don't take
me seriously
in my head i think that oh they're like
into me like you know that stupid young
confidence right yeah
and then
come like maybe freshman year
um i meet this girl online
and
she's in her 20s
but
we bond over hip hop and weed right
good combo i'm
probably thinking that i'm flirting but
in my head i'm just having great
conversations and i'm friending the hell
out of her today's video is brought to
you by master works do you think jeff
bezel has an i style ape jpeg hell no a
guy's way smarter than that plus nfts
are old news bezos is all about
diversifying now makes sense the world
lost 13 trillion dollars worth of stock
in the first half of the year and let's
not even talk about crypto that's why we
keep our portfolio looking like a
college admissions brochure we got
representation from all angles
diversified to the teeth exactly and
that's why big daddy bezos splashed out
70 billion for just two paintings no
apes involved bezos is into art
investing yeah man he knows that art has
some of the lowest correlation to any
asset it's a great diversifier man you
can't go all in on just [ __ ] coins maybe
that works for bezos but i'm just a
podcast host and that's where
masterworks comes in baby this platform
buys actual paintings not nfts from
names like picasso and banksy and breaks
them into shares so you're investing in
just a piece of the painting this way
you diversify into art without having to
sacrifice your firstborn son to date
over 500 000 users has signed up for
masterworks but you jk fam you can skip
the line by going to masterworks dot art
slash record again that's masterworks
dot art slash record see important
regulations and disclosures at
masterworks.com
cd so at this age i'm like 14 years old
she i know she has a boyfriend she knows
you're 14. she knows i'm 14. tired she's
like 22 or something like that 22 and a
14 year old any and then her boyfriend's
like 20 23 or whatever you got a game
dude so like that's pretty good just to
have a deep voice so like so like what's
up
i love hip hop and weed
and i met her online completely it's all
online right i was 13 last year
i was 13 last year
fyi full transparency i was just 13.
stupid and people are like you don't say
oh [ __ ] that's crazy
so back then like you just meet people
[ __ ] in chat rooms and you just hang
and whatever i've dude there's so many
times i could've gotten [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like i've been to raves with strangers
concerts oh yeah
i've been yeah like and it would be like
[ __ ] dudes that i make friends with
that are like 19 years old and they pick
me up and [ __ ] so a lot of things could
have happened as a [ __ ] vulnerable 14
year old boy
so like she
showed me like that so we become friends
this is me thinking like yeah she got a
boyfriend but that don't mean nothing
you know
[ __ ] stupid right that's what like
lots of r b artists taught us yeah yeah
yeah for real so she invites me to like
just [ __ ] go and blaze with her crash
whatever we're hanging out it's group of
friends right they come pick me up it's
her couple of her boyfriend's friend um
and then um
she lives right by little osaka or
saltel so i i like that area so you know
she's gonna take me out and go [ __ ]
get some food out there
we go to the airport where her boyfriend
works at he's a pretty boy mexican dude
right he's working at like a subway
there he intro she introduces me to him
he's cool whatever and it's like yo
after work let's let's let it get stoned
and [ __ ] and i'm like all right cool
and then um you know we go to we go to
little osaka we go eat and then we go to
our apartment we're hanging out he comes
back home from work
we're like blazing we're watching like a
horror flick all this stuff
and in my head i'm thinking
i might lose my virginity tonight to her
oh yeah
like a [ __ ] idiot to one of them
i'm 14 years old she's with a boyfriend
they're together and in my head i'm
still thinking
i'm getting lucky tonight she was going
to ditch him dude
no were you providing the weed
i had some weed they had some weed like
we all just kind of
just blazing all night right this joke
it always has weed bro
we were [ __ ] laughing all night you
know his friends are cool like half of
them didn't even speak any english it
was just all spanish but it was like a
room full of asian mexicans just like
smoking and like having a good time oh
yeah one by one people start like trade
relations bro and i'm just like oh [ __ ]
what time is it and i'm like oh [ __ ]
this is probably like too damn late to
go home right now and then i'm way too
[ __ ] high so like
um she's like yeah you could just crash
here and i'm like oh hell yeah it's
happening and then she busts out like
this [ __ ] soda you know that soda
with the with the bead yeah the rum yeah
and then she goes joey she calls me joey
she goes joey i got a soda for you and
at that moment i realized that some
fruit snacks i'm her cute little brother
i've got some tang and rice krispies
and joe's like yeah i am her [ __ ]
little brother
and then she went in the room and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of her boyfriend and i'm
sitting here on the couch
with a [ __ ] juice and i'm just
sitting here high as [ __ ] and i'm like
i didn't get [ __ ] tonight
mind you i'm still a virgin and i'm
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] looking back just
going he's like this soda do hit though
and we ate all night had snacks and [ __ ]
yeah the bad bunches
and then [ __ ] i woke up
high i was i still want to [ __ ] hi
i'm just like [ __ ] i gotta get home my
mom's probably worried about me
so she takes me back hope and after that
we just become hella close she becomes
like a true
uh like sister that i always like needed
i think what it was is like interesting
there was a she was she was basically
alone from um like out of state or
something so she had no family oh okay
we're both japanese right
her boyfriend's mexican all that stuff
and then i think
it became like this weird relationship
of like we both were like lonely and
wanted family this is right around the
companionship when my dad split my mom
was depressed and she was just [ __ ]
home like but in her own room not
talking to anybody
so then i think
she was kind of being that guidance she
saw something and it ended up like yo
she didn't we didn't [ __ ] but in return
i got a really cool bigger sister that's
a really nice outcome of them yeah yeah
that's a great story really good you
didn't [ __ ] your big sister i know right
no but she was way older than where
where is she now
i have no idea like somewhere in that
process like
you know being a 14 year old like kid
just drugged out all the time doing
graffiti jumping around from house to
house like
you don't really think and maintain
relationships well that's true so like
somewhere in that process i probably
found another set of friends who i was
able to just get stoned with
and then so
things just kind of moved into that true
yeah
dude you gotta try to find her that
would be so [ __ ] cool yeah
what if that was her
wouldn't that be [ __ ] hilarious
you gotta find her you gotta be like hey
just wanna let you know that first time
we met
i thought we were gonna have sex she was
like yeah i know
you were [ __ ] pitching a tent the
whole time
that's why i gave you a soda pop
to cool you off a little bit
the [ __ ] that a 14 year old thinks about
no dude to be fair you were high i mean
if you've never done it before you don't
know when you're about i don't know yeah
i don't know when it's yeah and you're
high yeah like remember how long we took
condoms with us like even though there
was no problem oh yeah just leave it in
your wallet
it's all melty i've never used any of
those you pulled it out it's like it's
been in there so long that like the
shape of the ring is like
fully pulling off the ink of like the
rapper that's a joke that's been in teen
movies since the 50s yeah that someone
keeps a condom for way too long and it
still resonates today
you really don't know and you think that
it's gonna spring on i still got the
same condom from high school you know in
my wallet
just in case no you just think you never
know for some reason i believe you yeah
and you were smart to believe me
dude yeah and those things get so dried
out when you keep them too long oh my my
not my dude not mine
oh yours was built to blast
built to last dude that's the name of
the brand actually
[Laughter]
it's dura last condoms
they make a good condo bro they make a
great condo that's a wild story man it
is
it's a really like wholesome ending i
know right you know i didn't know i was
sitting in a room full of losers that
never got to have sex with their older
teachers dude
kind of bummed out none of you guys had
sex with your teachers i thought i was
sitting here with a bunch of sexual
mavericks we really i think
the youngest teacher that even remotely
could be categorizes that in my high
school was the one that i told you got
in trouble she was like the mavis beacon
teacher or whatever that the mavis
beacon
yeah it's like a keyboard program teach
you how to type
and then she she ended up like uh
i guess like committing adultery where
like she had slept with a pastor of a
church that was uh that she was not
married to
so they they fired her whoa yeah because
you can't do that wow that's some
christian school [ __ ] yeah i asked out
one of my teachers in community college
that's interesting
so i was 19
and then i was taking stats at elac and
she looks like um you know the chick
that john cho ends up kissing in harold
and kumar at the end in the elevator yep
the hispanic girl yeah she looks like
like her oh yeah she was pretty high so
i remember so i remember in class i was
like oh [ __ ] she's super wait paula
garcia's
that girl she
is a daddy yeah [ __ ] she's everyone's
crush and then uh so i was just i was
doing like pretty good in class
and then the marine corps ball came
around yeah it looks like her yeah
the marine corps ball is like a like a
banquet or like a big like it's a marine
corps birthday and across the world it's
like a big like almost like our prompt
and so every unit will have like like a
craps tables it's just a fun time
so i emailed her i'm like hey the marine
corps ball is coming up this week i
would like you to be my date
and then i remember she replies back
this is inappropriate
and then and then i wrote back and she
was like this is inappropriate i'm your
teacher
and then i wrote back like a dumb ass
because then now my little eagle got
hurt i was like
pretty much i wrote something to the
effect of like news flash some of your
students are older than you
but i didn't say like in that
news flash
and then in that class
every single time i missed it uh i
missed class to have like drill which is
when you have to go train in the
military
there was a quiz that the next coming
monday
and i'm like what the [ __ ] this is way
too oh no way coincidental now
and so i think she like uh what should i
try to punish you i think so really yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know where you [ __ ]
up she's so cute it's because you
[ __ ] emailed it and you'd have the
boss to ask her and face them that's
what she meant but you know what because
if you email it then there's record yeah
there's a paper trail and she has to
force like she has to be like nah she
was really like amateur but if you asked
her like verbally then
you know she at least would give you
like hand job if she said no
100
paula garcia's man i saw um my piano
teacher was pretty hot in in um
in uh the commercial i mean the
community college we went to and then um
i remember this uh this one kid he
[ __ ] like studied japanese so he
could write
um miss whatever whatever is so hot or
like so pretty and then she was like hey
come in let me talk to you everyone's
like ooh
that's the best i don't know what she
said classic school i have no idea what
she said but his face was just like this
the whole time i don't know what the
[ __ ] got rejected
around after that she just like sucked
them off
she looked at the dick was like
[Laughter]
that would [ __ ] hurt man that hurt my
feelings right now why'd you do that i'm
sorry
you knew that wasn't hurt my feelings
dude let me see your dick nah dude
you're gonna laugh at it
that's what i'm still yeah but she was
hot though she's like if you are docile
and you look like i scold you really
hard for the rest of the school year i
will [ __ ] you right now
and he's like dude
you